are you still interested in aliens yeah
man this still so that's the thing when
I first came on your show yeah you cut
me really off guard because most most
people that we talk about aliens they
completely think you're crazy or you
disregard it's like yeah you gotta talk
about like you know the most people that
I attract with they're you know they
they so you feel like with zigge fuels
right then I and then after I found out
you you read a lot about that stuff like
the Sumerian text the creation tablets
acquisition and all that stuff and I do
too I mean I don't know if there's like
if there is a you know like III think
they would be life-form I don't if its
intelligence we don't have evidence for
it and I think or ego as human being
want us to believe that the alien came
and interact with us yeah that's our ego
but if they're that foreign advance from
us and they come from a different world
maybe they don't want to interact
because we have nothing to offer them
they're not gonna kidnap that farmer and
ask him what kind of suspension is
wearing you know what I mean like they
they think it you know what I mean it's
is but think about what you just said
about paleontology
I mean we're paying attention to stupid
[ __ ] lizards that lived sixty-five
million years ago it's true
I mean don't think they would be curious
this weird monkey with nuclear weapons
yeah but we don't communicate with it we
don't think tarik we observed there's
ways that again
learn from us without communique I don't
know I mean it's yeah I think it's our
ego that make us we want to feel special
we want to feel that that like are we
with different you know like we were
different beings then for example a dog
or yeah we can think because we're smart
but like I don't know how it this has
been giving a giving to us I can I don't
know you know like and you were talking
about it like when I was young I used to
have like you we talked about the last
time you said oh you you were talking
about like the experience I said I
remember that I remembered but I can't
recall it when I was when I was young at
I don't know if I dream I dream I used
to dry I used to draw figure of monster
I say my mom's is
Monsoor they come get me at night that I
was that's right that's what we talked
last time right but I was I was very
uncomfortable and I didn't want to talk
about it I was like man how the hell he
knows it you know everything man this
guy he knows everything he may research
and so I I made I made the drawing and
then my mom even now today today I want
to I want to see the joy you know like I
and I I showed the drawing and I'm like
and then I then after I remember later I
remember that I remember but I couldn't
remember you know someone I mean I
remembered that I remember that
something that happened but now I can't
remember what exactly happen right could
be a nightmare could be another slip
sleep paralysis or process and I my
imagination I don't have evidence you
know what I mean that's what we talked
about it last time and that's what
that's what happened to me and and and
and I hope I hope it's not me it's
nightmare you know what I mean but but
the thing is
later on I saw some documentary on TV I
saw some people that the similar
experiences me loss of memory and things
like this when they were young and they
claimed they they get a they get a
Hypno's and stuff then they they they go
back and time and they explained again
and abducted by an and then I start to
freaked out about it because I'm cement
is that what happened to me I know but
there was more a lot more logical
explanation you know what I mean
but that's why when he brought that back
I freaked no was this like how the hell
you know is this I guy I did I didn't
want to talk about it but any then it
was also my agent was there hey we need
in 10 minutes I'm like I didn't we were
misinformed we didn't know that podcast
was like that long in this house I all
these thing in my head I baby baby and I
didn't know what what to make of it you
know so that's that's what it was yeah
it's it's entirely possible that we're
experiencing something when we're
dreaming that were angry sleeping well
what unconscious that maybe there's
dimensions that consciousness travels to
that are non-physical that like this
this dimension what we're in right now
we can touch this table move this
microphone around yeah there's a
physical dimension
but it's entirely possible that whatever
your spirit is or your consciousness or
your your mind when when when you're
you're thinking of your thoughts your
soul that you say you say you said
you're a soul yeah whatever that means
you believe is this is a soul you
believe you don't know what that means
okay okay it's a weird word right it's a
really has religious connotations but I
agree but the idea of whatever your
essence is as a human being
there's something inside of all of us
that makes us conscious and aware and
and there and then that something is not
there when you're sleeping and so is it
dormant is it just recovering which is
you know the scientific version of it or
is it possible that while you're in this
dream state and your your body shuts off
that your mind and your consciousness
travels to a non-physical dimension that
you can only access through the
chemicals that are released in your
brain which we know produce psychedelic
experiences so if you took the chemicals
that are released during your brain or
inside your brain like
dimethyltryptamine and there's all sorts
of different psychedelic chemicals that
are produced by the mind if you take
these outside of you know the dream
state if you take these drugs you have
these crazy fantastic experiences and we
know these are produced by the brain
that produce a produce by the brain are
produced by the brain wasn't produced by
the liver and the lungs we believe
they're produced by your third eye which
is your pineal gland they've shown the
Cottonwood Research Foundation is thrown
that this this is done in rats
the rats produced dimethyltryptamine in
their pineal gland it doesn't
necessarily mean that people do but it's
logical to imply that people probably or
conclude the people probably do it as
well so those those chemicals that are
producing these psychedelic experiences
are being released by the brain but we
don't know why and we don't know what
they're doing when you sleep I gather
guy Mathieu Walker yes it was amazing
when you sleep your your guardian your
logic is not there that part of your
brain is gone yeah so we could that's
probably the most logical experience but
it's it's kind of a freaking scary
thought of thinking that man is a it
make you wonder sometim sometime you at
night that you're at night alone in your
thinking and I'm a I'm a guy that think
a lot you know I'm thinking about all
kind of sin or you like in a fight if I
think about it also no but in life in
the same way you're thinking what if
this happened for real or what if like
man it's sick
scary talk and it's it's it's a it is
nothing more scary in the world